there is nothing more satisfying than
watching a cheater get caught we all
love seeing the people who ruin games
get what's coming to them especially if
it happens live we've talked about
cheaters plenty of times before but
there's one special subset of gaming's
worst that we've never touched on
cheaters who got caught in the act but
before i tell you who made it onto this
list i have to remind you all that i'm
still hosting my vct watch party this
weekend friday saturday sunday 4 p.m
eastern at twitch.tv slash the score
esports and i want to see you there with
your spiciest takes possible okay now
let's get to it here are the dirtiest
cheaters who got caught in the act
today most of you probably know baby bae
as an amazing valorum player and my long
lost twin but at the very beginning of
his esports career baby bay went by flex
and played cs go that is until he was
vac banned mid-game while playing as a
stand-in for esp during an esea main
match in 2016. and uh we are coming live
into the 11th round now as it is going
to be a full buy from the ct side of
grandpa berets
yeah and we're going to see them you
know they need to start getting some of
that
some more
[Music]
flex
um
so that explains a lot i guess so that
must be the lag out so flex
has been banned on esea for
cheating
well i'm sure that stung baby bae went
on to have a successful career and not
just one but two big name esports he's
got his dash back and he knows that he's
going to take the shot and dash
even just wasted daggers why not as i
like to say people change
well you know it looks like esea just
flexed on him
oh
if you ever get caught doing something
shady just blame it on someone else that
always works out right miss q gemini was
a cs go streamer who was adamant that
her gameplay was totally legit
you know what's really sad that
sometimes you know because i'm female
and counter-strike people are like
you're cheating
[__] what shut the [__] up except there
was one little problem with that
oh my god i'm stupid dude
wait what the [__]
clara
hold on clara give me one second i need
to text my friend
clara right now she was at my house
earlier today what the i'm sure about
that
of course no one really bought into the
whole clara thing but plenty of people
got to have a good laugh about it guys
how did you know we can see the health
bars this is painful to watch dude she
didn't use a bot don't be because she
aims
bro
as for miss q gemini and clara all
that's left of the two is a youtube
account that has not been used in about
three years if i was her i nft that clip
and sell it dude that that clip is
golden it makes me laugh every time i
watch it
let's get something straight right off
the bat here shroud doesn't need to
cheat c still gets the kill it almost
looks like skadoodle had actually come
out on top there what a flick coming in
trout getting one of the headshots he's
tapping away shroud could he do it again
he's up to 11 kills and looking for
number 12 are you kidding me shroud but
there was one time where he decided to
take a flight on the wild side while
streaming pub g
he is harry potter
whiz can you
why man hello this was shroud's third
time encountering this particular hacker
but after the word cheats was uttered it
seemed like the streamer just decided to
plummet to his death to avoid
association
oh [__] can you take me yeah yeah i
actually sell these cheats for us
don't don't say a word
okay thank you i won't tell you anything
thank you
oh
i was aiming to land on the water but
because the flying car shenanigans
already helped shroud get a kill earlier
he was still banned from pubg for a
month i don't care what anyone says that
was the most enjoyable game of pub g
i've had in a very long time
it really goes to show
that pub g
don't give a [__] because that guy
should have been based
immediately
shroud may have some fun with cheaters
every now and again but the next
streamer on our list takes competitive
integrity very seriously grandpa gaming
has made it his mission to find identify
and punish cheaters whenever he'd come
across them this is wc berkeley stating
he's not cheating
and he wants uh proof that he is so
you be the judge
well he's over here now he's right here
right here
[Music]
that he warped away
elevator again
no no he was right here
i hit him and he walked away instantly
it's berkeley so you don't mess around
with grandpa but if having a former us
navy diver on their asses doesn't set
cheaters on the street and narrow well
then maybe sheer shame will when you're
out there busting your butt
especially at my age and with my
handicaps to get in the top five and
then get taken out by a cheater before
you get to number one i still don't
understand and a lot of people don't
yeah he's definitely running a name but
you shouldn't have to cheat in a game
period it's
i mean if you
if you don't have the skill don't play
the game
[Applause]
on the complete opposite end of the
spectrum we have a 14 year old former
fortnight pro and streamer k quid who
just like the whole clara incident
decided to blame someone else when he
got booted from the game mid-tournament
for cheating
y'all four like four views
what
who logged in
wait what
i just got logged out of my account hold
on hold on i think my brother i think
cake quid tried to deny any wrongdoing
but epic games wouldn't budge on the ban
obviously i'll i'm like 99.9 sure i'll
be unbanned
obviously because i never actually did
anything wrong i stream every single
tournament that i play at twitch.tv
forward slash credit plus another
fortnite pro came forward with some
pretty damning evidence including dms
between k-quid and an aim assist account
as well as a screenshot of k-quid's
desktop where you can see some
questionable programs but they say the
applications they use is v-droid scp
v-bus and universal control remapper
this is this desktop that is the exact
same applications as pc amis has said
look at the date down there v client pro
2020 04 14. it's not been two years
since cakewood's ban and it seems like
he really suffered from the consequences
of his actions luckily for him he is
still just 16 years old so he has plenty
of time to try again elsewhere
call of duty war zone is notorious for
the sheer amount of cheaters who play
the game buy me a car said there's a
cheater
what buy me a car is also like 13 years
old and i don't know if he knows if
anyone's actually cheating but if i get
fried i'll let you know
oh yeah
no pr
oh dude just i just got sniped from
tim the tatman is just one of many many
big time streamers who's been trying to
draw attention to the issue there's a
ton of hackers there's no really any
cheat and unfortunately for us we get
hacked on a lot hey
activision this guy
mini ninja in our game currently
cheating blatant cheating there you go
blatantly cheating
whatever you do to ban him he's
currently in our lobby thanks there was
only so much tim could handle before he
completely and justifiably lost his [__]
after encountering a cheater in his game
we all love the game tim we all love the
game
you hear me
i know you can hear me i know you can
you are so [__] bad
it literally
you can't even get up a ladder but you
have 100 kd right nice [__] automated
system dog [__]
of course i didn't really solve the
overall problem but at least him got to
let off some steam
all right
i feel better
well i am off warzone let's alt f4 not
gonna play that today
you've all probably heard this
incredible story already but if you
haven't you are in for a treat because
no list of cheaters caught red-handed
would be complete without optic india's
forsaken just look at how well he was
doing before the admins decided to check
his pc at xtreme's land zowie asia 2018.
and it's going to be a b split in
towards bomb site so they react
accordingly for sacred wood hot flash
into maine and he's gonna get three
frags crazy guy fog and jason all are
dropping he'll get the fourth as well
great work from forsaken the entry into
the b bomb so it doesn't go well
well that's a very long crazy spray
there for a second but he manages to
make it work closing out the round with
two kills forsaken and antidote i'm
gonna have to try and retake the site
luckily there is a hole in the smoke so
jose is gonna get some nice positioning
along the side
and he's gonna be able to get rid of fog
to the 2v2
nicely done onto the player out quad but
the bomb is still going to go down no
fake plan that works out well for optic
eventually uh there is a bit of a
problem with forsaken's computer i'm
told so it should be about five or ten
minutes once the jig was up the guy had
to be all but dragged away from his
computer while trying to delete the
infamous word.exe file that was in
actuality the cheating software he had
running in the background in one very
misguided fell swoop forsaken not only
destroyed his own career but his team
and pretty much the entire indian pro cs
go scene nowadays forsaken may have
fallen off the grid but the memes will
live on forever
forsaken.exe
oh too good.exe
what a god bro there's the balls to do
that on land i know
it is bad enough when you get caught
cheating by game's anti-cheats or by
some very observant viewers essentially
what was happening was we were playing
him and he was doing a few weird things
right like pre-firing spots you
shouldn't be pre-firing but there is
nothing more embarrassing than exposing
your own hacks and getting called out
you see right at the end here here's it
in 10 times speed look miss miss
terrible trey's got him down bad and
then all of a sudden lock
complete lock and you can tell right in
this clip when you end up seeing it just
how ridiculous it is so here's the
original clip that got taken off one of
the clips he had on stream before he
deleted it and if you kept an eye you
can see the red box is going across that
top left hand version here it is slowed
down um essentially what he's done his
display capture to try and show his task
manager and accidentally put the what
you can actually see so there's these
red boxes and the health bars at first
young tried to play the whole incident
off as an any press's good press sort of
thing but eventually both his twitch and
twitter accounts disappeared from their
respective platforms and young at least
under that moniker was never seen or
heard from again really obviously i
can't believe anyone was stupid enough
to actually put this up
and that concludes this episode of
listed this is just a small fraction of
cheaters of the world what do you do
when you run into cheaters in your games
let us know down in the comment section
below take care and i'll see you in the
next one
shroud is the one person in like the
sphere of like twist streamers and pro
players
that like i
desperately want the approval of he's
just has seems like has a good head on
his shoulders and i just i just want i
just want i just want that respect i
want that recognition and if i feel like
i don't have this respect i will do like
i will commit crimes to get his respect
and no jury will find me guilty